victorious was a popular Nickelodeon TV
show for teens before it was canceled
this show is about a young woman named
Tori Vega whose dream is to become a
star like every other TV show there's
always private moments that go on behind
the scenes in this video we'll take a
look at exclusive secrets about the
Nickelodeon show Victorious Jade I savor
your bitterness like a sweet rancid
cream sauce in the third episode of
season one everyone learns how to stage
fight during theater rehearsal class the
teacher puts everyone into pairs so they
could practice stage fighting with one
another during the stage fighting
process people use the safe word butter
nut to avoid getting injured while
practicing ever since this episode was
filmed the cast and crew of Victorious
would use the word butter nut on the set
whenever they were scared or annoyed
this really makes you wonder how many
cast and crew have their own special
lingo like victorious another
interesting fact about the stage bite
episode is that Liz did not have a stunt
double after the characters learn how to
stage fight they put their skills to the
test
Tory plays an elderly woman on her way
home from a bingo game and Jade plays a
mugger the mugger tries to steal the
woman's watch and the woman responds by
whacking the mugger with her cherrywood
cane Liz injured the fake wax all on her
own without a stunt double Liz was
completely fine in real life but Jade
gets a nasty black eye from the cane
smacking in a YouTube video created by
Dan Schneider he asks the cast of
victorious who they would eat first if
they were stranded on a desert island
the majority of the cast members picked
Leon as the one to sacrifice in this
situation because he's the most meeting
out of everyone matt said that he would
eat rax because he's the most expendable
Liz originally said that she wouldn't
choose anyone because she's a vegan and
could survive on plants but if she had
to choose it would be Leon everyone else
pretty much ganged up on Leon
except for Victoria even Leon said
when Dan Schneider casted the girls for
Victorious he realized he had four girls
with brown hair
Snyder explained that he wanted their
appearances to stand out a little more
by having one of the actresses changed
their hair color out of Victoria Ariana
Liz and Daniela Ariana was the one who
had to take one for the team in dire
hair red in the end
Ariana's iconic red velvet cupcake hair
gave life to cats character throughout
the victorious show Tori had various
love interests which included Daniel
Ryder and Steven Victoria's knowledge
and experience with romance on the show
was convincing but that's because it's
not the first show that Victoria had to
kiss on camera her first kiss was with
full Sprouse on The Suite Life of Zack
and Cody
she played a character named Rebecca on
an episode called the fairest of them
all if it weren't for her previous
experience Tori might not have been as
confident during kissing scenes as she
was according to an extra on the set of
the episode called Tori and Jade's
playdate Matt Bennett was making some
risky jokes the extra said that Matt was
making jokes about Avan Jogia SPAC egde
because he was wearing extremely tight
pants we can only wonder if not always
made risque jokes behind the scenes or
if this was a one-time occurrence
because of avens clothing that day Matt
seems like a pretty nice guy so it's
probably safe to say that he doesn't
usually indulge in scandalous jokes the
plot of Victorious included several
fictional plays which the characters
would take part in a few of the plays
included clowns don't bounce dang
it's lonely out here and uptown downtown
you might have noticed that the dialogue
in these plays is exceptionally bad
however this was completely intentional
Dan Schneider explained that the writing
team had fun coming up with a lame
dialogue he also stated that sometimes
lame dialogue would be created
unintentionally which wasn't nearly as
fun as when it's created intentionally
you might be wondering why the writers
would want to incorporate bad dialogue
intentionally it's probably to help the
audience differentiate what's part of
Victorious
and what's a play within victorious
without afternoon Matt bird left and so
what masked spirit Dan Schneider has had
quite a successful career he was the
creator of victorious zoey 101 The
Amanda Show Drake and Josh
iCarly Henry danger among a few others
before Dan worked on the creation side
of television he starred in a television
show himself when he was a teen he was
in a TV show called a head of the class
and played a character named Dennis
Blunden the sitcom was about a group of
gifted high school students that are
placed in an enrichment class together
the show follows their journey of
self-discovery and friendship the
density of oxygen on the planet marks
victorious ran for four seasons but in
reality the show was only three seasons
long the show was canceled partway
through season three instead of
finishing the season the remaining
episodes were aired later to make it
seem like the show had four seasons is
there were a lot of rumors circling why
victorious was canceled at the time Dan
made it clear that he had nothing to do
with canceling the show the decision was
entirely Nickelodeon's and was based on
the fact that most kids TV shows are the
most profitable when they run for about
60 episodes in the official theme song
of victorious there's a moment where
Tori catches a gold microphone although
she fumbles a little and then has a
silly surprised look on her face this
was because Victoria almost missed
catching the gold microphone while they
were filming this portion of the theme
song Dan said that he loved it so much
that he had to put it in the main titles
the opening scenes with Tori driving
with earbuds were also filmed during the
Golden Hour so that she could look as
glowy and gorgeous as possible in an
interview with elizabeth gillies the
actress said that the only thing she had
in common with Jade is that they both
look like bunnies despite the fact that
Liz and Jade have basically nothing in
common
Liz said that she loved playing the part
of Jade she said in the interview that
Jade is a dynamic character that's
always changing which is what makes
playing the part so exciting she also
went on to say that she could never play
a monotonous mean girl Liz said quote I
would just die if I had to play a
one-dimensional mean girl my favorite
toy was a hammer you finished the puzzle
victorious isn't the first Dan Schneider
show the Victoria Justice has been on
she also played the character Lola
Martinez on zoey 101
this was Victoria's first steady job as
an actress her work on zoey 101 is
considered to have foreshadowed her work
on Victorious in fact Lola's character
was also an aspiring performer with
dreams of becoming an actress it's
assumed that Dan used this character
template for the victorious show and
used a Victoria as the actress when
watching your favorite TV shows you
probably find yourself wondering what
goes on in between scenes according to
the cast of Victorious a big part of
working on a Nickelodeon satis playing
pranks on one another and eating
delicious food you would think that much
more dramatic and crazy things would go
on backstage but by the sounds of it the
cast of Nickelodeon shows are just like
any other work place or group of teens
it looks like celebrities aren't so
different after all you can't think of
one thing that you like about me I like
when you're sad
according to Victoria she hates watching
herself on the Victoria Show while her
friends are around this might seem odd
but when you think about it it would be
awkward watching herself on TV
especially with your closest friends it
could make you feel self-conscious and
take you back in time hopefully it's not
because her friends make fun of her in
2018 Nickelodeon announced that Dan
Schneider would no longer be producing
TV shows with the network at the time
people were shocked because Dan was a
major creator with the network many
people wondered why but there isn't a
clear answer there are rumors that
Schneider was predatory and abusive
towards his cast but no real accusers or
stories turned up people even commented
that Schneider would tweet photos of
girls feet from his cast other rumors
said that Dan's departure from the
network had to do with this infamous
temper apparently Dan blew up over the
network canceling his show game shakers
without a final episode on another
occasion dan supposedly became angry
when there was a change in management at
Nickelodeon Rex is considered to be a
main character of the show which is
Robbie's puppet in real life Matt is not
a ventriloquist
in fact Nickelodeon said that Matt had
to have special training for the role on
Victorious in the end all Matt did was
the puppetry of Rex on the show Rex's
voice was dubbed by Jake bear
which is uncredited maybe Matt took up
the art of ventriloquism after the show
ended oh this didn't take long to go bed
after Victorious was canceled Victoria
Justice had an unfortunate incident her
private photos were leaked the incident
happened in 2014 in Victoria initially
denied that they were her photos later
on she came clean and admitted that the
photos were hers this issue was quickly
swept under the rug as Victoria took
legal action this was a smart move
considering that Victoria was an
underaged actress at the time the leaked
photos did not have anything to do with
Victoria's cancellation because the show
had already ended however the incident
probably affected Victoria's
relationship with Nickelodeon and her
career that followed Avan Jogia was born
in Vancouver British Columbia in Canada
back the character that haven't played
on Victorious was also Canadian was this
a coincidence or two damn purposely cast
Aven for the role of back because he was
Canadian too we may never know for
certain
either way Ivan did a great job
demonstrating his Canadian side through
back on the show sometimes during or
after TV shows fans begin to ship
characters on the show or the people who
play them Victorious is no exception
many fans a shift at Liz and Alvin
because they're often seen being close
together and hanging out I've been
mentioned Liz in many of his interviews
and Liz said that she considered Alvin
to be a flirt Aven also had a nickname
for Liz which is Liz Miguel's they've
also been flirty with one another over
social media making fans wonder if
there's something more between them hmm
obviously the couple have some chemistry
together too many fans disappointment
the two victorious alumni never actually
dated wait the costume designer was in
your dressing room uh-huh
was she cute he was adorable
the old victorious news was save for
last it's no secret that Ariana and
Victoria didn't get along on the show
the few became super obvious during an
interview when the cast's were
discussing how Ariana sings a lot on set
Liz was supportive of Ariana but
Victoria chimed in by saying I think we
all sing while
rolling her eyes after this incident the
relationship between Arianna and
Victoria went downhill ariana opened up
about the issues on the set of
victorious with Seventeen magazine she
said that she was so unhappy working on
Victorious because someone said that
they didn't like her and never would
Arianna said that she wanted to fit in
so she tried to change her ways to
please everyone although this only made
Ariana miserable which is completely
understandable and that completes the
behind-the-scenes secrets of the
Victoria's TV show we hope you enjoyed
the video please don't forget to Like
and subscribe to the things if you want
to see more behind the scenes content
see ya